hey guys what I have for you today is a
video about benchpress form about why
you should try to flare your elbows
instead of tuck them here you see me
benching from the side the screen cap
here at the bottom shows elbow position
relative to the bar when the bars on my
chest and my elbows are tucked as you
can see the elbows are in front of the
bar and that creates an extraneous
moment arm that makes the lift harder
for you for the triceps it makes it a
little bit easier for the pecs so if
someone is strongest in this position it
tends to indicate that their pecs are
weak it's not necessarily good form it's
indicative of a specific weakness now
what you're going to see is me flaring
my triceps trying to flare and push and
then when you see elbow position
relative to the bar that straight line
drop down from where the bar is in my
hands to the 11 on process of my elbow
lets you know that that extraneous
moment arm is done away with the tricep
obviously still have to work out of the
bottom of the press but that's
distributing the muscular force more
equally over the pecs triceps the prime
movers of the bench now you see from the
top you can see basically the elbow
position relative to the rest of your
body here where I'm tucking it's a 30 45
degree angle and then when I flare it's
closer to about a 60 degree angle as
you're about to see so when you're
looking at someone bench press that's
what you should be looking at that lets
you know that their pecs are strong
enough for the movement and that either
they're not over tucking or they're not
just overly reliant on their triceps and
they have a peg weakness that they're
compensating for thanks guys